F3: So we have a new talking point about
coronavirus vaccines that is getting
oxygen. And the talking point is these are not
vaccines. They are. And then you can kind of
choose your own adventure. They aren't vaccines.
They are DNA modifiers. They aren't vaccines.
They are gene therapies, genetic therapies.
And there's a few other versions of it.
And it's actually been around for some time, but
it's now catching on more and more. Let's listen
to former Trump advisor and Breitbart propagandist
Stephen Bannon making this claim on his show,
some kind of show that he has.
M2: Let's take a listen to this
actual conversation and debate. These are not
technically vaccines, right? The first ones,
they're experimental gene therapies. Every
scientist I've talked to admits that. And here,
why can't you? I'm not an anti Voxer. I we're the
ones who look, this show is specialized in whether
you think it's a bio weapon from the Rouhani
lab that is let out on purpose or inadvertently
escaped or if you think it's a total hoax.
F3: So, Steve Benen, they're also actually gets
into the entire the virus is a bio weapon stuff.
But I mean, you know, we can't do everything in
one clip. Let's focus on what he said about
vaccines, because it's more relevant whether
or not you believe the virus is a bioweapon.
I don't think that impacts your interest in
a vaccine. If you believe that the vaccines
aren't really vaccines, that might actually
impact whether you want a vaccine. So let's
focus on that. Steve Bannon says these are
not technically vaccines. They are experimental
gene therapies. And this has been floating around.
And the kernel of this, where does this come
from? The kernel is that with a so-called
normal vaccine or so-called real vaccine, the
body is developing immunity on the basis of
a deactivated or weakened virus that is in the
vaccine. And that is what generates the immune
response. Now, these MRSA vaccines, messenger RNA
vaccines, they don't contain deactivated virus,
but they contain sequenced virus and
instructions that they say, quote, modify
your DNA. That's the talking point. It's a it's
a DNA modification. But let's go piece by piece.
First of all, Steve says it's experimental.
What does he mean by that? I don't know.
MRN, a vaccine research has been going on for
decades. They've been studied for flu, Zika,
rabies and scurvy vaccination. So
experimental. Not really. It's been
it's been studied for decades. Second, and this
is probably the key part, the Maryna vaccine
contains instructions for your body to make
the spike protein that the coronavirus has.
So the idea is your body makes all these spike
proteins. If you get the live virus in you,
the body recognizes that protein because the
Maryna vaccine already told the body how to
make it. It doesn't make you sick because it
quickly, quickly dispatch's with the real virus,
OK, where they get it's not a vaccine is that
it is not a weakened or deactivated virus
that is triggering your body to make the spike
protein. It is messenger RNA and RNA triggering
your body to make the spike protein. That doesn't
mean it's not a vaccine, it's merely a different
method of achieving the same thing. So
it's not experimental. It is a vaccine,
it's not a gene therapy, and it doesn't alter
your DNA. Everything Steve Bannon says is untrue.
Now, let's continue to another piece of the clip,
which is equally lie riddled. Take a look at this.
M2: They're going to get to a part of point
very quickly. If you don't have the vaccine,
you're not going to get the vaccine
passport. And in other words, you're
not going to be able to get on a plane. You're
not going to be going to public transportation.
Basically, you're not going be able to hold a job,
OK? And yet they don't want any debate whatsoever,
not from people. The anti vaccines of people just
have legitimate. Hey, can you walk me through
this again? What phase of this is really testing?
F3: It's got emergency authorize use by the FDA,
so now he goes into it will be mandatory
vaccination, as evidenced by an airline might say,
if you want to fly with us, you need a vaccine
certificate or Live Nation or Ticketmaster or
whoever might say. If you want to come to a
concert at one of our venues for which we sell
tickets, you need a vaccine certificate. First
of all, that's not the government making anything
mandatory and it's not the government doing
anything at all. Those are private companies.
Second is Steve Bannon saying that the government
gets to tell private companies you can't require
proof of vaccination. Is that I mean, the these
are small government free market conservatives
who seem to want it to be made illegal by the
government for a private company to say we
if you want to avail yourself of our product
or service, we require you to show proof
of vaccination. If requiring vaccination is
bad for like imagine Delta or JetBlue says,
you know, after September one, after January
one, you need to be vaccinated to fly with us,
which they haven't done, by the way. Maybe they
would if they do that and it's a bad business
idea, the market will punish them because all
of the unvaccinated people who want to fly
will switch from Delta or JetBlue to some
airline that doesn't require a vaccine.
That's the market. Well, what if every airline
requires a vaccine? Then the free market has
created an opportunity for a new airline to come
in and take all the customers that want to fly
without being vaccinated. That's how right wingers
sell us on the magic and efficiency and perfection
of free markets. And yet now they're using, yes.
Conspiracy theories that aren't going to become a
thing to, I guess, argue for the exact opposite,
which would be very heavy handed regulation by
a government they tend to claim shouldn't be
involved in regulating private industry unless
absolutely and completely necessary. These people
are not just pathetic, but they're spreading
dangerous conspiracy theories that reduce the
number of people who might want the vaccine.
And it's get it's like whack a mole. It's getting
harder and harder. In fact, I even have. I even
as a as a visual aid, I even have my my gavel,
it is like playing whack a mole here, trying to
tamp down all of these different conspiracy
theories. And Steve Bannon certainly not not
making any easier. We will have more coverage of
this and other vaccine related conspiracy theories
on our Instagram at David Pakman show. And you can
follow me on Instagram as well at David Pakman.